This is the team from
Sorted Food,
and today, I am ripping off
one of their formats?
(laughter)
I don't know if that's the right—
In exchange for a
shameless plug of our app(!)
We are doing
"Remote Control Chef" today,
and I am being remote-controlled.
What's gonna happen?
Basically, we have a walkie-talkie,
you have an earpiece,
and we direct you
'round the kitchen, taking in turns.
Yeah, you're gonna become
our remote-controlled chef.
We're each gonna talk
you through a dish,
and then he gets to judge
them at the end.
I get the best job,
judging the dishes,
but also the process and
the chaos that gets you there.
Why do you get to judge?
I wear the jacket.
Right, that's fair.
What you have is one
lovely bag of grocery ingredients,
and from that one shopping list,
you're gonna create three recipes,
two portions of each, and...
...zero food waste
if it all goes to plan.
Right! "If it all..."
I feel like the last part of that sentence
was the most important.
'Cause I... I'm not a good cook.
Like, I never really got
beyond student—
Join the group!
Right, okay.
Usually in these kind of battles,
you have a Chef and a Normal.
This time, you've got a Normal
and someone who's even more Normal.
(laughs)
So this could be interesting.
You had, what,
ten years of Sorted Food now?
Yeah, but we've had a terrible teacher!
(laughter)
We have picked
three recipes that will...
be a little bit cheffy, a little bit
kind of flavour combinations,
some super-seasonal stuff.
Who's going first?
Our most normal Normal.
Heyy!
Oh, that's...
Wow, I've been promoted(!)
(laughter)
Tom?
Yeah.
Are you ready?
Yeah, sure.
I've got a funny feeling I'm gonna
enjoy this more than you will.
Yeah, that's probably right.
30 minutes, right?
30 minutes.
Ready... steady... cook!
Okay, well I've got
a bag of stuff.
And... what do I need
from it first?
So today, Tom,
we'll be making a beautiful
pea soup and gremolata sauce.
That's right.
One of those words you used
sounded like "gremlin-ata",
and I do not know what it is.
Gremolata.
So to start off with,
in the bag,
you should find some
delicious shallots.
Yeah, perfect. We're gonna
need to halve, peel,
and then finely slice
those 200 grams.
Halve, peel, then finely slice, okay.
This is the only bit of chopping,
I think, in this entire recipe.
So, you wanna... take the...
Take the ends off.
Take one end off.
And then cut it in half
lengthways.
Down there?
Yeah, but I'd do it flatly.
Yeah, perfect.
I mean, I'm sure my knife technique
is terrible here, but...
See, one of the things I do
when I'm cooking at home
is I cheat
and I use a lot of
pre-sliced, pre-diced
frozen vegetables.
Which is why my skills on this are
a lot worse than might otherwise be.
Alright, so next job is peel?
Tell you what, if you wanna
mix it up a little bit,
we may as well start
preheating a pan.
Alright, little splash of oil.
'Kay. Good, right.
That's... heating up.
There's we go, alright.
Keep peeling.
Nearly.
Totally— Oh for—
No, that didn't help.
(plosive wheezing)
Fine, that's peeled, okay.
Right, now you can discard all the skins,
just chuck them in the bin.
Oh, for god's sake,
there's still more here!
Right, we're five minutes down.
And so far we have peeled some onions.
Five min—?!
The thing is, we also only used
half the pack of shallots,
so I'm gonna have to do this thing again
in another recipe, aren't I?
Yeah, that's the beauty
of these recipes.
We share the ingredients
across the entire week.
Yeah. That's—
That's shal-lot.
I'm not gonna get tired of that pun.
I've only just realised I can probably do
two at a time here, can't I?
Yes, brilliant!
Vaguely patronising.
No, honestly,
that is genius,
'cause I've never thought
of doing that before!
(both laughing)
Yeah, that's working.
That makes so much sense.
I should do that all the time.
Now chuck all of that
into your pan,
and then you wanna basically sprinkle
a little bit of salt in there.
That'll help bring out
some of the moisture.
What's next?
Okay, so this is for our
gremolata sauce.
It's essentially like a lemony,
garlicky, green sauce
to go on top of our soup.
So to start off with,
30 grams of parsley.
Chuck that into the measuring jug
that we're gonna be blending in.
There we go.
Okay that's it. Got it.
Then you wanna drizzle in two tablespoons
of the darker, posher-looking oil.
Now you wanna peel
one clove of garlic.
I've never actually used
fresh garlic in my life.
How?!
It's the best ingredient
known to mankind.
I know, and it's also
a complete pain in the ass!
Compared to just getting pre-sorted—
Anyway, here's— It's peeled.
Chop off the bottom of it.
And then you can put
the knife on top of the garlic
and then put your weight
on top of the knife.
That's it, perfect. And that makes it
a little bit easier to take the skin off.
Oh yeah, alright!
Okay.
I'm gonna be honest, I very rarely get to sit
in this seat and give instructions,
but I am thoroughly
enjoying myself!
(sighs)
Right, so that beauty
is gonna remain raw,
and you're gonna chuck it
into that blender mix.
Yeah, man.
Okay, in it goes.
Because you're
so good at peeling,
we're now going
to be peeling a lemon,
or otherwise known as zesting it.
Right, yeah.
That I can do. Okay.
You just want the yellow bit.
The pith can be a little bit bitter.
Alright. That's enough.
That's plenty.
If you get that
straight into the mix...
Yep, okay, good.
Now also, can you cut a lemon in half
and squeeze in its juice?
Yes.
Perfect, now we want
to blend that up.
That's on.
Yeah.
And there's a button
marked 'Turbo', so cool.
Let's do turbo.
Right, next up, you want to grab
the bag of frozen peas.
Yes.
And chuck that into
the pan with the shallots.
So, believe it or not,
we're nearly done.
This last bit will take
about five minutes.
Now, I'm not sure
where this thing is,
but if you wanna go
hunt around for a stock cube.
Yep, if you crumble it up,
and chuck it in there,
that's just instant seasoning.
Wonderful cheat ingredient,
this or...
vegetable bouillon,
however you pronounce it.
So now add just a little bit
of water from the kettle,
which should be behind you,
and you wanna just cover the peas.
'Bout there then, I think.
Yeah, nice.
One thing I forgot to do
was preheat the grill.
I've definitely got the grill here.
Two little wavy things at the top.
That's— I think so.
Then whack it on full.
Got it.
And then you wanna grab
a ciabatta loaf from the bag,
and cut that in half lengthways.
Cool. Alright, that's done.
That's in half.
Now you can bung those
straight under the grill.
Oh god, where are the oven gloves?
'Cause the rack,
if we're going for the grill,
needs to be on the top
just there.
Thank you, Tom!
I forgot that bit.
(laughs) I'm not a complete id—
...Never mind.
I think all we’ll do now is
wait for that to come to a boil,
and then we're gonna blend that up.
Alright!
Is this gonna spray
boiling water at me?
I think if you keep it
on the bottom, it should be fine.
But yeah, get a shield
just in case.
Alright, there we go.
I'm gonna turn the heat down as well,
'cause it's really puthering here.
That's totally a word, and not just
something that I made up(!)
Okay, so the thickness
is definitely right, 'cause it's now...
...acting like it's a damn volcano!
I'm gonna move it off the heat.
That's perfect, right.
Can you just check
the ciabattas quickly?
Oh my god, I forgot about the ciabattas!
They burn really quickly.
Okay yeah, we're fine, we're fine,
we're fine, we're fine.
Not fine! They're burning!
That's...
Oh.
Oh yeah, no.
They're— They're toast.
Whoa-whoa-whoa.
They can always be saved.
Let's have a look.
It's bad!
(crew laughing)
It's bad. That's fire-alarm bad.
That's pretty bad.
They can still be saved.
Don't worry, I've been there.
Let's get 'em out,
and then... oh no.
We're gonna do the trusty
scraping of the bread trick.
Okay, well, we were doing so well!
We only have a minute left!
Could you not shout
when I'm just touching—
I thought I was just about to burn—
We only have a minute left!
Also not helpful!
Get a bread knife, and scrape some of
that delicious burntness into the bin.
I mean—
Use the back of the knife.
Come on, you've been here before.
We've all had to save our bread.
(mouths silently)
I can see you!
(laughs uproariously)
Yeah, but I wasn't talking
to your camera!
(laughs)
No, this is...
The only thing I think I can do is
cut this in half like that, and...
...maybe, if the bread knife is sharp,
go down here like this,
being very careful with my fingers.
Yep. Be careful, be careful.
Yeah no, that's— It's dead.
You did a really bad job.
(snorting snicker)
(crew laughing)
Tell you what, Ben won't know.
We'll serve it upside down.
There we go!
Yes, that'll do!
It's good enough.
Right. I'm so sorry.
Good!
Little bit of texture,
little bit of burn is great.
We've got 30 seconds.
Can you check the seasoning
really quickly?
Get a spoon in there,
make sure you're happy with it.
I mean, what difference
is it gonna make?
It'll taste better.
Mmm!
Happy?
That's really good.
Okay, get that in the bowl.
Okay, in the bowl.
Half of that, because that's
supposed to serve two, but never mind!
It's a big bowl!
Fine, we've got a sharing portion!
Because you share soup, don't you(?)
Sharing bowl of soup! Lovely!
Yeah, okay, fine!
And then this on top.
Now you want a nice drizzle on top of this.
Yeah, it's too thick for that.
Little drips...!
It's not a drizzleable sauce, this.
And then let's get some wonderful
extra virgin olive oil.
Then just a nice drizzle over the top.
See, that I can drizzle.
Yeah, look at that!
Now we're cheffy!
(through chuckling)
That's a sharing portion of soup.
Three, two, one.
See? It's easy as that.
(snorting chuckle)
(stifled laughter)
I don't know if you can hear the crew
cracking up over here, but...
I mean, I will say this much.
I will say this much.
It actually tastes really nice.
Zingy? Fresh?
Yeah.
Nice. Recipe one down.
Two more to go.
How we feeling?
I mean, you'll notice,
through the magic of editing,
that the kitchen is a lot cleaner
than it was a little while ago.
So yeah, it's fine. Who've I got on the
other end of this at the minute?
This is Jamie,
and we are cooking
crispy mushrooms with
curried cauliflower purée.
We've put 30 minutes
on the clock,
and the time starts...now.
First of all, let's preheat an oven
to 200 degrees Celsius.
Okay, oven is on.
Lovely, now can we source
a large frying pan?
When you say /sɔːs/...?
Well... pull one from somewhere.
Right. Not like, sauce.
No. Like...
Have you got one on the hob?
Lovely, that's perfect.
Let's get that on a high heat,
and can we add about
four tablespoons of oil into it?
Let's rip those wild mushrooms up.
So like, just that? Literally...
Yeah, perfect.
Just rip 'em up.
What would be handy is some sort of
mechanical device to make this faster,
but you said rip, not like, blend or
shred or process or anything like that.
Tell you what, why don't we pop
some of those mushrooms into the pan
whilst we continue to rip?
Let's do that. Yeah, okay.
That's getting quite full there.
There's... There's...
There's not mushroom[much room] inside.
The great thing about
mushrooms is they will—
Just no-sell my pun,
why don't you(!)
We've been doing this for
twelve years, Tom.
Honestly, we've made
all the puns that we can.
I'll be honest, it feels like I've been
ripping mushrooms for twelve years.
Yeah, we've had to watch you!
(laughs uproariously)
(crew giggling)
I've just figured out the technique
for ripping these faster.
Seven minutes in.
I heard that look
you just gave to camera!
Do I know you gave the camera a look?
No, not at all.
But you just gave the camera
a look, didn't you?
Yes.
Yeah, okay. You just Office'd me.
(giggles)
Let's start the purée, shall we?
So, to start our purée,
we're gonna need a cauliflower please.
A cauliflower, yes.
Slightly unusual, we're going to grate it.
Alright, how hard can it be?
I'll tell you what,
you've a very good grater here.
...Thank you.
Tom, I'll be honest,
you're doing a fantastic job,
and I'm proud of you.
That sounded sarcastic.
I'm not sure if it was.
No, it's encouragement.
Positive mental attitude.
We've got this.
Right, get the rest of the
grated cauliflower into the saucepan.
Yep.
Alright.
And now let's get
the frying pan into the oven.
We're about halfway,
which is, you know, it's great.
So, why don't we find...
200 grams of shallots?
Oh god, not again!
Oh really, it sounds like
you got prior experience.
Yeah, you weren't in
for the last time I did this.
Prepare for whatever the opposite of
a master class in cutting shallots is.
There are gonna be people grumpy
about my cutting technique here,
but I haven't learned the fancy
thing that keeps your f—
I feel like if I try to learn that now,
I would cause more problems.
Should that cauliflower be
on the heat, or anything like that?
No, not yet. We're going to
throw in the shallots.
We're also going to peel
and thinly slice some garlic.
Oh good, good, excellent(!)
And some ginger.
We can cheat if we want.
Let's just grate the garlic.
Then you don't have to peel it.
It's the best cheat ever.
Well, that's a better idea.
What a revelation!
'Cause the skin just doesn't seem
to be going through the grater.
The skin just comes off.
I take back all the sarcasm and
looks to camera I had earlier.
This has just saved so much time and
made me so much happier.
And if you want, we can do
exactly the same with ginger.
You've got quite the speed on there.
(crew giggling)
Honestly, your hand is blurring.
You can shut up, crew!
(giggling intensifies)
Alright, in goes that as well.
Now, I feel like this should be
on the heat by now.
It will be on the heat
in about 60 seconds' time,
after we have poured in
500 mL of milk,
and finally, just a tablespoon
of curry powder, please.
Essentially, we're going to bring
the milk up to a boil,
and once it's boiling,
we're gonna reduce the heat
down to medium and
simmer it for 7–9 minutes.
Okay, how long's left on the clock?
Seven minutes.
Cool.
(crew laughing)
Right, okay. That's mixed.
Did the milk go in there?
Yes.
500 mL of milk went in here.
Oh good, okay.
Well, look out for that bit.
Don't get—
These are not my ingredients
or my instructions, mate!
You're the one in control here.
I'm not taking—
I'll take the blame for the
crap cutting. That's on me.
The amount of milk,
that's on you!
Right, I think that's
all mixed in, that's perfect.
Let's get a lid on that,
and that'll help to boil it quicker.
Yeah, okay.
Let's go check on the mushrooms.
Make sure they're not burning.
We can probably,
with your tea towel,
we can probably remove that pan.
Now, that handle is gonna be hot.
Yes it is, so it needs to be...
I'm gonna put it on the surface here,
and just get everything out of the way first.
Oh yeah, they look crispy.
Deep, golden-brown,
that looks ideal.
Now, a little tip for you.
Don't touch.
Keep the tea towel
on the handle.
That's a really good idea.
Do we have a small
measuring jug nearby?
And the blender.
Yes.
Then we need to get our hands on
100 mL of crème fraîche.
I just touched that pan!
Thank you for the tea towel.
That was a good call.
We'll need about a third of that jar.
Okay.
Can you add the whole bag
of coriander in, please?
Maybe keep a couple of stalks back.
We'll use that for garnish.
Alright. Seriously, this is just
coriander and cream. That's all we need.
Coriander, crème fraîche,
blend it up.
It's gonna go a lovely green,
and then we'll season it to taste
with a bit of salt.
Remember, you can always add more.
You can't take it away.
I've discovered the problem.
I put the salt and the pepper in
while the blender was still in there,
so it's all just sat on top
of the blender.
It's just there. It's just sat there.
(giggles and wheezes)
You might not be transmitting, but I can
hear your laughing from the next room,
so thanks for that(!)
(laughs)
Honestly, any mistake you're making,
I've made a hundred times before.
So that's why I just wanna
take this opportunity, Tom,
to say you're doing a great job.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm gonna choose to interpret
that as not sarcastic!
I'm not being sarcastic!
So many people bought Displates
after their last sponsorship here,
that they've come back!
This time, they wanted to
show off their larger plates,
and all the licensed art
that they have.
So they sent over a few
to give to my friends.
This print of the
original Star Wars poster,
and this shot of the
Enterprise-E from Star Trek
are gonna fight it out on the walls
of one friend's office.
And then this poster of
The Flash looks wonderful
with the glossy print on actual metal.
I know who I'm giving it to.
This is probably gonna end up
right over their TV.
All the Displates come with a
fancy magnet mounting system,
so you don't need any tools
to put them up.
and you can get their 3D magnets,
so they seem to hover away from the wall.
And there are also Displates for
video games, comics, even NASA.
They come in gloss or matte,
or framed up if you like.
And there's also a lot of
more artistic poster options
if you'd prefer not to fly
your nerd flag quite that high.
As this video goes out,
it's their summer sale.
There's a link in the description
and pinned comment.
And even if you're watching this later,
that link will still give you a very good discount.
Right, back to the show.
We now have our mushrooms,
are cooked and ready to go.
We have our coriander cream...
...blended and ready to go,
and seasoned to taste.
Let's taste one of the
mushrooms, just quickly,
and see if that needs
any more seasoning.
Needs something.
There's not as much -
what's the word - umami in there
as you'd expect from those mushrooms.
I'm gonna add that pinch of salt.
Lovely word, umami.
Time-wise, I think we're just
gonna have to go with the veg.
It's gonna have to be done.
Alright.
Okay.
(mouths silently)
Don't— I saw that!
So let's take the pan off the heat,
and we're gonna get the blender
straight into the pan.
We wanna blend that up
until it's silky and smooth.
Okay.
Okay, Tom.
We got two minutes left.
So does that blender have
a super-speed on it?
I'm using it!
(wheezes)
Is that the turbo mode?
Yep!
This is what
arbitrary time limits do to us.
Yep. (chuckles)
If you're cooking at home,
just spend five more minutes
on it. It'll be great.
What we're gonna want to do
is create a lovely...
mound of it on a plate,
right in the centre,
lovely circle of it.
Alright, say when.
Excellent, okay.
And let's get
half the mushrooms on top.
Now let's spoon half of the
crème fraîche over the top.
Make it as cheffy
and arty as you like.
Fifteen seconds.
Yeah okay, fine.
Yeah, you know what,
that's happening.
(crew laughing)
Do you mind?!
Oh, cheffy and arty,
just how I like it.
That's definitely
a thing that happened.
We'll let Ben mix that in, shall we?
Okay, three, two, one.
Gonna be honest with you,
made some errors there.
That— That could be a lot better.
It could be a lot worse...
...but it could definitely
be a lot better.
Once again: teamwork,
joint responsibility.
We'll take this one together.
Hello, Tom.
Hello. Who have I got?
You've got Mike here,
and I'm afraid we're faced
with a dichotomy.
Oh, good word.
Thanks.
I hate losing to the other guys,
but I'm also the weakest in terms of
cooking ability out of them.
If your instructions are clear,
we're gonna be fine.
What are we making?
(distant laughter)
I heard that laugh on
"We're gonna be fine"! I heard that!
Okay, visualise this,
this is what we're making:
some mac and cheese
flavoured with spinach,
with little dots of crème fraîche,
grated cheese melted on the top.
It's gonna be
unbelievably delicious,
and it's gonna be a breeze to make!
(laughter)
You don't believe that!
Even through this headset,
I heard the disbelief in that.
I can't even lie to you
via walkie-talkie!
This sounds delicious.
30 minutes?
30 minutes. Start the clock!
First thing we're gonna do
is cook some pasta.
'Kay.
So you have your macaroni.
Now, if you grab some
scales on the back...
They weren't there earlier!
I put them there for you, because
great prep equals great results.
Alright, yes.
I'd like you to take the big pan.
200 grams of macaroni
is gonna go into there.
Close enough, 209.
I haven't cheated,
but I have pre-boiled a kettle.
Pour that all over the top of the pasta.
We're gonna wanna season that water.
Because with pasta, we want it
to take on lots of seasoning.
So, I would put a lot of salt in.
And I am going to set you
a timer for eight minutes.
Alright!
Look at me, remembering stuff!
Yep, got it. Lovely.
I've actually gotta do it now.
Can someone set me a timer
for eight minutes, thanks.
(crew laughing)
I outsourced that job.
I thought you might've done.
Now we're gonna create
a roux.
Ooh! I know what that is.
I've seen all the chefs
on YouTube make that.
I've never made one myself.
I'm excited about this now.
Yeah, it's like
flour and butter, right?
Absolutely. With a little bit of milk in,
we're gonna turn that
into the cheese sauce
for our mac and cheese.
Plain flour then.
We want some flour.
We want the scales still,
and we want some butter.
This is probably 500 grams
of butter. Yeah, okay.
I would say 50 grams
we're gonna need.
Alright, that's probably about
that much at a guess.
The fact that you're already
eyeballing ingredients
shows what an amazing cook
you already are.
Well, it's 500 g,
I want about a tenth of it.
That's exactly 50 grams.
I've nailed that, lovely.
Okay...
So get that onto a medium heat.
We're gonna basically
get that all nice and foamy.
When the butter goes foamy...
Yeah.
we're gonna start adding
some flour in,
and that will be four level tablespoons
into the foamy butter.
Is that a dessert spoon or a tablespoon?
It's a dessert spoon, but hey!
You're eyeballing it. You're at the
eyeball stage of your culinary career.
(chuckling)
While we're waiting for that to foam,
you could grab a grater,
because actually, also into this roux
is going to go some garlic.
Yep. How much garlic.
Lots of garlic for this, surely.
We've got ample garlic.
Do you know what?
I would say,
season to taste with garlic.
Can we grate this directly in here?
Is that now, or...?
How foamy is that looking?
I mean, have a look.
You've got a camera.
That's still melting a little.
Yeah. Is it right up high?
You said put it on medium,
so I put it on—
If you're gonna throw back
my errors in my face,
then you're just gonna
make me look silly, aren't you?
Yes...!
Well, this is how Sorted works.
That's fine. Teamwork.
Teamwork. We're fine.
If that's melted,
let's get some flour in there.
Right, so one, two,
three, four heaped—
Oh, level, level, level, level!
Oh, well that's two then.
There you go.
Eyeballing it. Professional.
And we wanna coat
all of that flour in the butter.
Make sure that it cooks right out,
and we're looking for a sandy paste.
I feel like roux is one of those
things I've always looked at
and gone, "That's gonna be a complete
pain in the ass to make", but that's worked.
So we're gonna cook that out
for a couple of minutes,
because it'll basically get rid of
that raw flour taste, which no one likes.
It steadily gets browner and browner, right?
That's right. We'll keep an eye on it.
But you're doing a great job!
Thank you.
Despite your instructions!
This feels easier.
No one has asked me at any point
here to peel and then chop
200 grams of goddamned shallots!
There are no shallots
involved in this recipe.
I'm very happy with that.
And thank you for introducing me to
a genuinely new feeling in this studio,
of happiness and contentment!
(laughter)
I mean, likewise! This is working.
It's all gonna fall apart shortly.
Let's be clear.
But right now,
this is seeming pretty good.
Little bit of boiling going on there.
I feel like that's something
that shouldn't be happening.
I think we've cooked the flour out nicely.
So we're gonna get some milk in now.
Right, okay.
We're gonna do it bit by bit,
and I will need you to measure it.
Tom! Stop!
I've already messed it up.
We need to put garlic in first.
I'm terribly sorry.
So now we can grate the
two cloves of garlic in first.
Okay.
Nearly didn't get away with that.
As soon as you've done that,
we're coming up to
eight minutes on the pasta.
So let's get it off the heat
and test it
to see if it's cooked
to your liking.
How do you like your macaroni?
I should've stirred—
Al dente, if we can pull it off that way.
Let's see what it's like.
Another culinary term.
You're a pro.
Yes.
Fantastic!
If anything, that's slightly too much done,
so probably about right for mac and cheese.
Let's get it out of that hot water then.
We'll drain it.
There's a colander that
I've strategically placed.
Well done, that man!
Marvelous!
Excellent!
Pasta, done.
Happy with this, lovely.
That's good.
We need milk in this.
How much do you need?
You needed me to measure this out.
Yes. We need 400 mL of that milk.
Got it.
Fantastic.
And we put this in slowly,
one bit at a time, right?
Yeah, imagine doing
a quarter at a time.
Okay.
How're you feeling?
More confident at this point
than anyone else here.
This is—
I'm loving these instructions.
They're clear.
The recipe might feel
a little bit simpler?
I don't know if that's—
Right.
But we've got a roux involved.
You're shooting me in the foot here(!)
No, I think it feels simple because you're
giving good instructions. How's that sound?
I love you with all my heart.
(laughs)
I think we're good.
I think the last of this can go in.
Is it nice and thick.
There you go, it's getting hot.
Yeah, we're getting there.
This is gonna be amazing.
Yeah, happy with this.
You are a perfectionist.
We are gonna get on like a house on fire.
Are you happy with the smoothness?
Yeah, what I—
The important thing that I can't see
in here are any lumps of roux.
There's no lumps of flour I can see.
It's all just little dots of garlic.
That's because you're a
bloody professional, that's why.
I'm enjoying the mutual admiration society
we've got going on here,
but I think the clock's ticking, so...
(Mike and crew laughing)
Right, what's next?
So, you should have
a bag of spinach there.
And we're gonna use the whole lot.
Dump this in?
Dump it all in.
Right, okay.
And it will get to a point
where it just all wilts,
and then you'll be like,
"Oh, I thought I put spinach in this."
Right, every time!
And while that is wilting,
I'll get you to chop up
about 10 grams of coriander.
'Cause we'll chuck that in as well.
That's a lot of spinach, isn't it?
It really is a lot of spinach,
but I just keep—
I keep pushing the spinach down,
and it keeps going in.
It's like Mary Poppins' handbag!
That's how much coriander I've got left.
Take a small amount.
I'd say about 10 grams,
but yeah, that'll do.
That much?
Yeah. In the left hand.
Just chuck it straight in the pan,
'cause we're gonna blend this up.
We have eight minutes left.
Agh! Okay, cool.
Alright, what's next?
I've prepped you a hand blender.
We're gonna grate in some cheese,
and then blend it,
but we do need the spinach to wilt.
Everyone's using the hand blender.
Everyone's using the hand blend—
That's already got one on, mate.
(crew laughing)
...Did you prepare this?
I prepared this,
and in doing so...
set up a hilarious... scenario.
Yeah, you did.
Cool. Alright. Let's go.
Now can you try and incorporate
some of the roux onto the top of the—
Yeah, that's it. 'Cause the more sauce
that gets on top of it, the quicker it'll wilt.
Great job.
I'm doing my best.
It's steadily wilting.
So let's prep what we're
gonna put into this pan now:
50 grams of cheese,
it will be one tablespoon of mustard,
and crème fraîche, 100 grams,
so maybe five or six tablespoons.
Simple as that. Good.
Bosh!
Okay, give it a quick stir.
Now let's blend that up!
That is looking awesome!
That's looking really good.
I'm happy with that.
Tom, have a sniff. (sniffs)
Can you smell that?
Yes.
That smells like team spirit.
Right, I'm guessing it's just
put the pasta in the sauce
or the sauce in the pasta.
Which way around do you want it?
Well, I've got a spoiler.
We're gonna put the pasta on a
baking tray, cover it in the sauce,
and then we're gonna put
some cheese on top and grill it.
I'd like to grill it for 4–5 minutes.
We're not gonna have that chance.
But we've got three minutes remaining.
Macaroni on there.
And then we're gonna grate
25 grams of cheese on the top of it.
Let's get that under the grill
for our remaining minute and a half.
Oh-kay!
Maybe we'll go over!
Let's prep the remaining bit of
coriander and crème fraîche.
'Cause you're gonna dollop
that on the top,
and then we're gonna tuck in,
and we're gonna win this competition.
I don't really wanna open—
How much time have we got?
I mean... 30 seconds I would say.
Okay, right, cool!
Have a look, see.
How's it doing?
All we want is that cheese to melt.
It's melted!
Is it nice colour?
Does it look lovely?
It's not brown enough,
but it's gonna have to do!
Okay, okay, okay!
But you know what?
That looks yummy.
I'm happy enough with that.
All over the place,
wherever you like.
We're gonna mix it all in,
let's be honest.
And then we wanna tear
some coriander over the top.
About five grams worth.
I think...
...that will do nicely.
And we've got a three,
a two, a one.
♪ Ta-da ♪
I'll be honest, that's the one I'm happiest with.
I just don't know how it's gonna taste.
Great work! Get in!
That was the most difficult cooking
I've ever done in my life.
And I realise
that's a very low bar,
but I'd never tried to cook
against the clock.
I've never tried to cook
something like this.
Normally, I'm just
at home and just,
"Yeah, that'll do."
Trying to follow a recipe...
that is being translated
to me on a time limit.
So did you see what was going on?
I was peeking occasionally.
So I saw the chaos and the carnage,
and some in places
very, very concise.
And you have kept these warm.
We have, yeah. We've hot-held them.
And therefore, it might've lost
some colour on the peas, but—
You just kept them
warm with your hands?
It's a kitchen term.
I'm sorry.
I thought "hot hail" was the thing that they drop
in Flash Gordon to destroy the earth.
I think we should just tuck in.
This is... a pea soup with a sauce.
It is, and you can tell that I didn't know
how to use the immersion blender.
I got a whole pea in that bite.
(laughter)
It's a variety of textures.
The flavour's solid though.
The recipe is really good.
That tastes amazing.
The gremolata is so zingy
on top, isn't it, as well?
Yeah.
It's those little tricks,
of the raw garlic and the coriander
in that little... jus-y sauce,
that lifts what is otherwise
a very tasty pea soup.
It's absolutely delicious, and is...
a brilliant use of frozen peas that
you've thrown together in half an hour.
This I'm less sure about.
Dish number two?
It took me so long
to grate the cauliflower...
that I feel like we lost
some cooking time there.
Also I was really bad
at cutting the shallots.
I will take the—
What, you hadn't improved from the first round?
I think, had you had
an extra minute of cooking,
it'd have been smoother,
rather than that kind of texture,
but it smells, as you were cooking it,
amazing with all those curry flavours.
That shallot needed
a few more minutes,
and it needs to be finer.
That's on me.
I'll take responsibility as well.
Teamwork, as we said at the time.
But if we hadn't crowbarred
a time limit into it...
for the sake of urgency,
then you'd have got that perfectly smooth.
Again, it's a dish with two component
parts that work really nicely.
With the crème fraîche and coriander
on top, that kinda takes it a little more cheffy.
It tastes great.
Little bit of that raw shallot.
Yeah.
And a little bit of that pulpy cauliflower,
an extra minute or two would've been great.
But...
It's also really peppery.
I think it was the curry powder.
Was it?
Yeah.
Which leads us to...
Everyone's favourite, mac and cheese.
Spinach mac and cheese.
You couldn't be arsed
to plate up?
We didn't really have time
to plate up.
We didn't want to plate up.
This is how we serve it.
Dare I say it...
Wot?
It's like a 'healthy' mac and cheese.
There's so much veg going on there,
that it's fresher than you think
mac and cheese should be.
I feel like I undersalted that,
or something.
It feels like I needed to put
a little bit more in there.
Little bit more seasoning, I think.
But that, I think that's great.
Tom, have you got a favourite
out of the three?
Based on flavour and
approach and method and—
I think it's that one.
In terms of instructions—
I'm taking credit like
I created the recipe(!)
In terms of instructions,
I think we got on better.
What do you mean?
There was just—
There was a mutual admiration society.
At no point was I in blind panic.
So I feel like that's—
That's a good start?
I know. Can you believe it?
What happened to you?
I don't know.
But if we're going
in terms of pure recipe,
and what I would want
to eat again,
That's really nice.
And I think what's key,
and the whole point of these recipes,
is that behind Jay, is no food waste,
with the exception of
wait, the coriander that Jamie was
supposed to garnish his plate with!
(laughter)
Do I have to pick a winner?
Yeah.
That's the format. (chuckles)
(laughter)
Oh yeah, I did say I was going to judge this,
wasn’t I? Okay, how about this.
I have a loser.
Hi!
(laughter)
And that is that dish today,
just based on time
and not being able to blend it smooth enough,
even though the flavours are great.
I think that's on my skills,
rather than your instructions on that one.
Oh, no.
Teamwork, joint responsibility.
It's fine.
We like to pass the buck
in this studio,
so give this guy the buck.
I think for remote-control chef...
the instructions and results
were best...in dish three.
Oh, yeah!
Mike's mac and cheese.
(laughs)
(applause)
It's been a true pleasure.
I never thought I'd say
that having the safety net
of Mike in your ear would
create calm environment.
That's not how this
normally works.
I never want to hear
that sentence again.
Thank you very much, folks.
That was lovely.
Man, great job.
It's been so much fun.
Thanks for coming down.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]